bioshock 1 has one of the most genius
stories i have ever seen its central
plot is brilliant and the attention to
detail when it came to its setting in
world building is arguably a masterpiece
just on its own today i want to look
back on bioshock's story and uncover
what really made this one of the best
games of all time despite it being 14
years old as always spoiler warning
ahead for the whole story of bioshock
and with that let's get started as
always we need to start at the prologue
but for bioshock we need to go back even
further that title bioshock it's such a
bizarre word when you think about it
many games have a very distinct title
with weird meanings but at least i could
tell you what the words mean cyberpunk
2077 is a game with a cyberpunk art
style that's set in the year 2077. a
game like dragon age is a bit tricky as
i've never played dragon age before so
while its title as a whole makes no
sense to me i can at least understand
what the individual words mean dragon
age and origins and maybe draw some
conclusions about the game but what is a
bioshock i like many might think it's a
homage to system shock 2 which was
irrational games first project but
furthermore it could also be a shortened
version of biological shock which in the
context of the game makes sense given
how adam ruined this society and how our
protagonist acts throughout the game but
we haven't gotten there yet so i'll
return to this in a moment as we start
the game the player needs certain
questions answered in order to feel
invested in the story who are we how did
we get here and does the story make
sense bioshock creates a sort of meta
narrative based around these answers but
once again more on that at the end of
the video our first interaction with the
game is a cutscene and bioshock wastes
no time getting right into the action as
the plane were traveling on crashes in
the middle of the atlantic ocean we
awake amongst the wreckage and need to
find land the only place within eyesight
is a giant lighthouse next to us i've
always seen this lighthouse as a beacon
of light in a dark time although it's a
bit more literal in this case as the
only light we can see is the moon the
burning plane and this lighthouse as we
enter the door shuts behind us and we
see a giant statue of a man with the
phrase no gods or kings only man written
on a banner while it's confusing as is
this confusion should actually start
earlier why is there a lighthouse in the
middle of the atlantic ocean even if we
were to ignore that why isn't there
people in the lighthouse there's so much
wrong with all of this and while that
does sound like a criticism i actually
find it to be a wonderful decision as
it's making the player question
everything they see it's also the start
of many mysteries this game will tease
to the player which causes them to
become more invested in the world around
them in an attempt to find out more as
we head down the stairs we see three
plaques with the words art industry and
science written on them while a violin
cover of bobby darin's beyond the sea
accompanies us in the bathysphere what's
important to remember is why we're going
in this submarine we're in the middle of
the ocean and it's the 60s even if
others had survived that plane crash who
will be going to call for help our only
option is this bathysphere as it's
either this or swimming at night in the
atlantic ocean and i'll take my chances
we presumably descend deeper into the
lighthouse while a message plays from
andrew ryan someone who looks oddly
similar to the statue upstairs bioshock
has many memorable moments and this will
be one of three key moments throughout
the entire game i have rejected those
answers
instead
i chose something different
i chose the impossible
[Music]
rapture might be my favorite setting in
any video game ever made not just the
idea but the reasoning behind it is
brilliant the fact that a city not only
exists at the bottom of the sea but also
functions at the bottom of the sea is
something that has never been done
before andrew ryan also says that
rapture was made for those who do not
fear censors or morality it's a judgment
free place but not in the sense of
people getting along and being happy
together but a place that allowed those
who wanted more to get more injured ryan
says that the surface was constrained by
laws and ethics but rapture was no such
place and it's because of this ideology
that allowed rapture to blossom into
what we see now a bustling city under
the sea completely shut away from
society at least that's what it seems
like until we actually enter rapture our
first encounter with the city is a very
grim one as we're going to be introduced
to a man named johnny until we get to
see him sliced open right in front of us
we then meet with johnny's killer who
screams at us before attempting to open
the bathysphere it's possible that her
anger is the same as the people who used
to be here as there are signs everywhere
saying things like ryan doesn't own us
let us leave and the rapture is dead
earlier i talked about a light that
shines in the darkness when i brought up
the lighthouse atlas is like the
lighthouse but in a more metaphorical
sense as atlus saves us from this person
who is trying to kill us his charming
demeanor and attitude makes him
instantly likable and that is further
reinforced by his own actions as once
again he's trying to save us we push
further and are able to arm ourselves
with a wrench we can take a couple
practice swings to test out our new
weapon but we can also get a look at
these splicers atlas was talking about
as they aren't alien creatures but they
don't look human anymore everything
seems to be going smoothly so far given
the circumstances until we see the
gatherer's guarded vending machine
[Applause]
hold on and everything will be fine
[Applause]
look mr bubbles it's an angel
i can see light coming from his belly
wait a minute he's still breathing
it's all right
i know he'll be an angel soon
i can't explain to you how genuinely
terrifying this was when i first played
the game currently we don't understand
what a big daddy or a little sister is
just yet so seeing a tiny child with a
syringe as big as she is walking with a
moving scuba suit is probably the most
terrifying thing you'll ever see we also
discover that we can now cast
electricity through our hands which is
just another bizarre and crazy thing
that rapture has we also get a look at a
concept that is shown throughout rapture
and it's how the world continues to
reinforce that you're underwater it's
not enough just to have a few windows
that show the sea but the effects that
the outside environment can have on
rapture such as the plane wing crashing
into the tunnel causing all the water to
flood inside there are even smaller
instances of this such as the water
falling from the ceiling or just puddles
of water in places where it shouldn't be
bioshock also shows other problems that
rapture can have like a lack of
electricity or when this elevator falls
and instead of just being a cool scene
to ramp up the destruction we can
actually see someone walk out of it
while on fire it makes rapture seem real
as it showcases how a place like this
can have problems but also what problems
a place like this may face like water
damage and poor infrastructure if you
want to go even further than this this
is also the first showcase of how the
splicers interact inside the game as
this female spicer is trying to sing a
lullaby to her baby despite it being
quite the frightening tale she's talking
about how her baby's gonna be sold by
the pound once her dad is gone and how
she'll be alone when her parents are
both dead except it seems like she's
losing her mind as she's struggling to
figure out why her baby doesn't feel the
same anymore until we realize her baby's
actually a pistol atlas was also
listening in on this lullaby as he says
that it was the plasmids that caused all
the chaos there's even an audio log not
even a couple minutes later that
captures one of the moments of rapture's
downfall here's a toast to diane
mcclintock
silliest girl in rapture
silly enough to fall in love with andrew
ryan
silly
[Applause]
[Applause]
it seems that an explosion went off
during the new year's eve party
presumably right where we're standing
which killed numerous people we don't
know why but if we're to believe atlas
plasmids caused it in some way later we
get to see the little sister and big
daddy again and are able to observe them
without the fear of being stabbed and
it's quite the brutal scene it shows the
dynamic relationship between the two and
also the importance of the little sister
and the strength of the big daddies we
learn that the little sisters gather at
em while the big daddies protect them
from people who want to harm them it's
also assumed that people might want to
harm the little sister because of the
atom that she carries after some
fighting we make it to the end of the
intro where andrew ryan appears and
notices that we've invaded his city he
asks for a part of the cia or kgb as he
probably assumes that the only people
capable of finding and infiltrating his
great city would be the government and
he also thinks that the government
either wants to put an end to his city
or nationalize it to things he'll never
let happen despite being just a voice
for a majority of the game it's his
personality and the power in his voice
that makes him feel like a threat and
i've always liked how impressive the
voice acting was for him of course we
have to escape his ambush and arrive at
the medical pavilion ending the tutorial
bioshock's intro is pretty much perfect
we get a cohesive set of circumstances
that show how our character made it to
rapture and then get introduced to what
rapture looks like how its inhabitants
interact with the city and a few pieces
of information for the player to think
about like plasmids adam big daddies
little sisters and the downfall of
rapture there is even a ton of things we
still don't know yet like who we are who
atlas is and how the plane crashed and
while i do wish more backstory was given
on this once you beat the game you
realize it's impossible to talk about
right now there was so much mystery with
bioshock from its setting to its
characters to even the actual plot that
it makes you want to learn more and
while this information and mystery can
be considered overwhelming when shown
all at once these mechanics characters
and locations are everywhere so it's
hard not to remember them and it also
gives the player something to go off of
instead of being left in the dark all
game it's also been like 15 minutes
since we started the game so it's not
like it's been four hours of game time
without any answers we're just getting
started so having a bit of mystery is
perfectly fine this early in the game
and the way this is pulled off in
bioshock is expertly done from here
things start to become harder to talk
about as bioshock's main world building
device is the audio logs we find
scattered around the map there is a
common critique amongst gamers that it's
unimersive when there are audio logs or
recordings scattered throughout the
world as it makes no sense that this
many people would be using them when
talking about the most mundane of topics
and while i definitely agree with this
sentiment i've always just chalked it up
to a limitation of game design
especially in the case of bioshock where
there are no npcs the player can talk to
to learn about rapture so all their
information has to be from the audio
logs thankfully there is a ton of them
in this game and are extremely easy to
find as they glow and are more often
than not found in areas you'll be
traveling through anyway these provide
lots of context to rapture's downfall
and explain a lot of what's going on
around the city except they are
everywhere throughout the game and not
placed in the most linear fashion for
example we see these ghostly apparitions
throughout the game but it isn't until
we get to arcadia roughly 3 or so hours
into the game where we finally learn why
we can see ghosts i have no problem with
the way these audio logs are structured
it just becomes a little harder to
explain when making a video about it so
for now we'll just be going in the order
of the game intended and occasionally go
off the beaten path to discuss some
other aspects of the game like right now
as it's a perfect time to talk about
rapture itself as i said before it
wasn't just the scenery of the city that
made me love rapture but it's what it
represents that intrigued me just like
the title of the game we need to address
the main name of the city rapture by
definition is a feeling of intense
pleasure or joy but it's also a
theological belief within christianity
assuming my research is correct it's an
event that would be the end of times
where those who are faithful christians
whether alive or dead will be taken
above the clouds to meet the lord all
those who are not faithful will not be
taken up thus are condemned to whatever
destruction the rapture brings rapture
the city relates to this as you can
infer that this place above the clouds
would be considered a paradise for all
christians so rapture is a place for
those who want to experience a paradise
away from the mainland as ryan said it's
for the artist who doesn't fear
censorship or the scientist who isn't
bound by a petty morality rapture allows
the creativity of the mind to be the
only limit within its walls and this is
why the city of rapture had so many
scientific breakthroughs the residents
of rapture never needed to worry about
whether or not what they were doing was
unethical dangerous or controversial as
they were given complete freedom rapture
essentially went through a never-ending
golden age of technological advancement
people were able to conjure elements
through their hands and were able to
have not just their facial features
reconstructed but their entire gender
and even their race changed as well even
though it all went to [ __ ] eventually
just the concept of rapture is genius
it's incredibly thorough and really
highlights the stellar writing of this
game as the biggest question that comes
to mind is why build a city in the ocean
and yet the devs managed to not only
give an answer to this question but
actually make it quite believable
continuing where we left off we had just
escaped andrew ryan's ambush and have
made it to the medical pavilion
according to atlas this is the direction
we have to head in if we're to save his
family i said earlier how bioshock's
intro showcases how some of the splicers
interact with the city and while in that
case it was just a small example this
concept gets brought up again but with
more depth added to it from the moment
we enter the pavilion we see signs and
posters of a dr steinman he's the
overseer of the medical pavilion and is
also a very accomplished surgeon one
thing you'll notice about bioshock is
how all the name characters have a story
about them each character has a
backstory and a reason for coming to
rapture and all their stories tie into
the overarching story of rapture each
area also has a distinct look to them
and a reason for being in the city and
both the levels and characters within
them all tie into rapture in some way
which we uncover from the audio logs dr
steinmann performed cosmetic surgery on
the people of rapture but due to the
circumstances of the city he too became
corrupt due to rapture being a place
where people can show their truest forms
and are able to push the boundaries of
their studies dr steinman would use this
time to perfect his craft everything was
going well until the discovery of adam
as this sparked an idea in steinman's
head as he thought this was a perfect
opportunity to revolutionize the
industry hoping that with this new
technology surgeons could sculpt any
kind of flesh with ease but this of
course led him down a darker path see
steinman was a perfectionist and of
course when you're a perfectionist your
standards are incredibly high but adam
managed to push these even further
adam presents new problems for the
professional
as your tools improve so do your
standards there was a time
i was happy enough to take off a water
to or turn a real circus freak into
something you can show in the daylight
but
that was then
when we took what we got but with adam
the flesh becomes clay
what excuse do we have not to
sculpt and sculpt and sculpt until the
job is done
dr steinman didn't go crazy just because
of adam it was a combination of adam
rapture and his inability to let the
smallest problem go he would change
things that patients didn't want and
given that he's a professional in his
line of work he used this to reinforce
his actions why argue with the
professional after all they know all
there is to know steinman lost control
and began working on anyone he wanted
even if they weren't a patient of his
his final decline is how we see him in
game he moved away from the faces of his
patients to their whole physique
claiming that this one was too fat or
this one's too tall or that this one is
too symmetrical he ended up losing his
mind when he was introduced to adam he
wasn't an addict to the drug but an
addict to his work he saw the potential
of adam and his first thought was how
far can he go without thinking how far
should he go this shows that adam and
even the policies of rapture affected so
many of its city's residents and due to
their different fields of study and
different levels of wealth and social
status we're able to see how it affects
everyone differently this style of
storytelling is flat out genius it makes
you want to go to the next area and
uncover what the level is about what it
provides the city of rapture and how its
unique setting caused its unique
downfall no game has ever gotten me to
care this much about one small level and
i find that in itself very impressive
after we have dealt with dr steinman we
enter the second key moment of bioshock
as we approach this hallway we see a big
daddy get thrown through the wall this
is the first time we have not only seen
a big daddy up close besides the
cutscene from earlier but we actually
see one defeated so it must be a really
tough opponent who brought him down
except it's just another splicer even
though i've always found this almost
impossible to happen that's not the
point of the scene as now that the big
daddy is dead the little sister is alone
the splicer takes this opportunity to
grab the little sister so he can take
her at him but a mysterious woman shoots
him before he can do that i'll bring her
up in a moment but right now she and
atlas give us a choice these little
sisters contain atom the core foundation
of rapture and if we can get more we can
buy more plasmids and tonics to get
stronger but we're also doing so at the
cost of potentially killing her rescuing
a little sister will net us 80 adam but
she lives harvesting her will give us
160 but she dies it's a case of morality
are you willing to sacrifice the life of
a little girl for the benefit of your
own especially when you uncover their
origins it makes the choice even more
important the little sisters were a
creation of tenenbaum the woman from
earlier after discovering a sea slug
that was able to cure the wounds of a
smuggler when it bit him after some
research on the slug she discovered what
caused this anomaly and dubbed the
substance atom she also discovered that
had the ability to splice people's dna
giving them the opportunity to
essentially have superpowers leading to
the creation of plasmids the problem
with atom is that on its own there
wasn't enough to change anything but
tenenbaum found a way to create atom
inside people's bodies but once again
this also failed as it wasn't enough the
only test that worked was with young
girls which was the start of the little
sisters another problem arose is there
wasn't enough girls to go around as who
would willingly subject their daughters
to this experiment so fontaine can
spread with tenenbaum to create an
orphanage that would be used as a front
to exploit the children and specifically
take the girls to use them as hosts for
adam despite how creepy they may look
when you rescue them you discover that
they are just in fact little girls not
some mutant creature but a living
breathing human she with the assistance
of a dr shu chong who we'll get to in a
moment subjected the little girls to
mental conditioning so they can become
valuable hosts so she cares enough about
the little sisters that when someone
else hurts them she'll defend them but
when she hurts them it's okay her logic
is clearly flawed and there is a reason
for that that she feels awful about what
she did but the majority of the audio
logs we find say the opposite this makes
tenenbaum a hard person to trust which
not only reinforces the game's concept
of morality when it comes to the little
sisters but also strengthens the
relationship between you and atlas it's
a great idea on paper but horribly
executed in games sadly according to
tenenbaum if we save enough of her
little one she'll give us a reward this
is in the form of a present near the
plasmid vending machines that has atom a
plasmid and some other items like ammo
and eve the number of atom is consistent
every time so for to compare the two we
find out that every three little sisters
rescued gives us 440 atom assuming you
collect the present and 480 if we
harvest all of them if the player were
to rescue harvest all 21 little sisters
they will get either 3 000 80 atom or
3360 atom respectively this is already a
problem on its own but they continue to
add more items for the player easily
making rescuing the best option without
even thinking about the morality of the
situation a 280 atom difference in the
grand scheme of things is really not
that big of a deal especially when you
get to the end of the game when you can
upgrade your plasmids that run as high
as 180 atom now maybe i play the game
differently than others but i never
needed many plasmids during my
playthrough i wasn't constantly starved
of atom i just needed a few important
tonics and some go-to plasmids and that
was it you really don't need an entire
arsenal of tonics and plasmids to
complete this game unless you're doing a
sort of challenge run or something what
they should have done was kept the
rewards from the present but cut the
atom we get from the gifts and rescuing
in half going from a total of 3 360 atom
if you harvest them to 1 680 if you
choose to rescue all of them this also
cuts your survivability in half all
health and eve upgrades are 80 atom each
buying all of them throughout the game
will set you back 1280 atom leaving you
only 400 to use on upgrades and plasmids
so it creates this situation about
whether or not you should dabble in more
health or eve or use the atom to upgrade
your plasmids this would make saving the
little sisters a lot harder to do and
force the player to actually choose
between rescuing or harvesting them are
you still willing to stick to your
morals and never harvest one no matter
how hard it gets or are you going to
cave in furthermore are you going to
justify your actions or live with the
fact that what you did is wrong if you
plan on justifying it aren't you no
better than the people who live here
like steinman who used his work as
justification for his ruthless actions
or the loads of other people will meet
soon who also did evil things because
they were furthering their field of
study i'm also not the only one that
thinks these rewards should have been
handled better as the creative director
for the game even agrees yeah and we
went back and forth a lot about what the
rewards for harvesting versus saving
would be and actually i think we should
have
really
pushed further that the rewards for
saving
were much more much more should have
been much more meager than the rewards
for harvesting you probably have noticed
by now that we've spent a lot of time
talking about dr steinman and the little
sisters but not about the actual medical
pavilion itself and this is where
bioshock tends to suffer a bit the
medical pavilion level has 17 audio logs
the player can find and only eight of
them aren't made by dr steinman while
this sounds like a great opportunity for
the other logs to introduce more lore on
the other doctors and patients bioshock
doesn't do this the other eight audio
logs are random logs like andrew ryan
talking about the vandalism of vending
machines or dr shu chong testing out a
new plasmid you could have put these
anywhere else in the game and you
wouldn't bat an eye as they fit anywhere
since their story isn't related to a
specific area it's not a bad decision to
make these kind of audio logs but it's
clear that it makes it harder to fill
the others with more content about the
actual level it makes the medical
pavilion seem only about dr steinman and
not the other people in the pavilion
thankfully the environment does attempt
to assist them in some ways but the rest
of the level lacks in any sort of story
outside of steinman this also isn't a
level issue but more of a whole game
issue sometimes it always feels like the
world revolves around specific key
people and never anyone else our next
level is a great example of the opposite
as neptune's bounty has no end boss well
sort of and we'll get to that regardless
there are 19 audio logs in here and
there's a very diverse cast of
characters within them as most of them
have between three to five logs each on
top of this majority of the logs add to
the level's ecosystem neptune's bounty
was used as a cover up for a man named
frank fontaine and his smuggling ring
many items inside rapture were
considered contraband as that would
disrupt everything rapture was built for
and a large majority of these audio logs
aren't about one person but the area as
a whole such as when tenenbaum
discovered that slug we talked about
earlier this links to the creation of
adam but also adds to the level itself
as this discovery was found here there's
also an audio log about a man named
sullivan who is a detective for andrew
ryan who's trying to find evidence
against fontaine his audio logs show the
steps during his case as he attempts to
interrogate a smuggler of fontaine's we
can actually find the location of where
this interrogation happened in the level
and this also relates to the level as a
whole again as this is where fontaine
does his smuggling so it would make
sense that a detective would be here
this is the weird problem with
bioshock's audio logs but i do want to
make one thing very clear i do not hate
the concept of these logs there are
great ways of providing lore and world
building to the game even if they really
shouldn't exist as we discussed earlier
plus they're audio logs not notes
meaning the player can walk around and
explore the level while listening to it
rather than sitting still and reading
text however it's very clear that there
is some favoritism and inconsistency
with these audio logs where one area
will have most of logs be about one
character another may have it be about
the actual level and sometimes it's
neither it can make the story harder to
follow at times as events may occur
earlier than when they get explained and
can also be the opposite where something
gets explained but then is shown to the
player later with the hopes that they
remember it getting back to the actual
story neptune's bounty is the next level
we come across then as i said earlier
there is technically no boss in the
level at least bioshock's version of a
boss as peach wilkins doesn't have that
audio log treatment that many others got
like dr steinman he only gets three
audio logs throughout the game so it's
clear he wasn't intended to be a boss or
main character of an area just a
roadblock for the player to go around
this is further reinforced by him
denying us access to smuggler's hideout
and subsequently atlas's family until we
can get him a research camera i'm not
the only person to say this but from a
story and gameplay perspective this
camera is very video gamey the fact that
a camera is able to analyze genetic
material from a simple picture is a
possible stretch that i'm willing to
just barely forgive but it is in no way
entertaining to start a fight with a
camera so you can snapshot a picture of
your enemy then get back to fighting at
the end of the day it's a really small
part of the game so i tend not to dwell
on this too much the fight that follows
though has always been a blast to do as
it forces you to get creative with your
plasmids incinerate can be used to open
up more doorways which double as cover
and sources of eve and ammo furthermore
you can make this encounter much more
entertaining if you picked up the
security bullseye from earlier and don't
even get me started about new game plus
as this makes this encounter even better
peaches is a bullet sponge however and
does take numerous hits to die from
pretty much anything but it does add to
the intensity of the fight so i didn't
really mind it after somehow making it
out alive we arrive at smuggler's
hideout where the cora fontaine
smuggling ring is located despite it
being the shortest level in bioshock it
does an amazing job showing off its
environment as all these boxes we see
throughout the level are the contraband
fontaine was smuggling in we also do get
to see a flashback appear on screen when
we enter the area this isn't the first
time we've seen one and it won't be the
last but it's relevant later so we'll
leave it for now it's also here where we
finally meet up with atlas and help him
rescue his family we let atlas through
the door and we watch as he attempts to
free his family ninja ryan comes on the
radio and mocks us saying maybe you
could warn him or if only you could do
something except just stand there and
watch him die on its own it's exactly as
it sounds but i've always found this to
have a double meaning after knowing the
ending of the game but just like the
flashbacks and the tons of other things
we've talked about before today we'll
talk about that later we run down the
stairs to help atlas but he is
overwhelmed by splicers and needs to
fall back but as we approach the sub to
finish the job he started it explodes in
front of us this is a turning point for
the game atlas the man who saved us and
who we can consider to be a dear friend
of ours had just watched his family die
in front of him atlas and now the player
will want revenge for this and the only
person to enact that on is andrew ryan
that's why our next objective is to find
the bathysphere in rolling hills as this
will take us right to andrew ryan
himself our next level arcadia is
simultaneously where the middle of the
game starts and also where it starts to
plummet in regards to the story from a
gameplay perspective this is just like
the previous levels but with new
plasmids new enemies more upgrades and
different environments i thoroughly
enjoyed the gameplay when going through
these sections but it carries the levels
as there isn't much story to go off of
however i will admit that there is the
occasional audio log sprinkled in the
next few levels that is very important
to understanding the backstory of
rapture and that there is a very unique
sense of style to these places as they
all serve very unique purposes arcadia
is a literal forest of trees which is
how rapture is able to produce oxygen
despite being hundreds of feet under the
water however the majority of the audio
logs in arcadia are dedicated to one
person julie langford the creator of the
arcadia forest except she's not a main
boss like steinman in fact she helps us
which is a nice change of pace but her
audio logs don't really add much
substance one talks about her tests
regarding this lazarus device and how
she wants to test the rosa gallica
flower to see its results but she was
unable to due to a recent lockdown if
the bright colors and presentation
weren't obvious it's clear from the
audio log that these flowers will be
important later even if you didn't piece
that together she'll have you go fetch
one anyway so it doesn't matter if you
caught on or not another talks about
this cult with an arcadia called the
satarin except it's just about how they
steal her equipment and how they believe
they're touched by the gods we do get to
see this cult in the game as all the
houdini spoilers in arcadia are a part
of the group but nothing else is
developed they're just a cult with no
motivation and no real reason to exist
as from what we gather from the audio
logs they just drink human blood and
plasmids steal julie's research
materials and are avoided by many of the
people in rapture as they brutally kill
anyone who isn't a part of them the
question is though why well if the wiki
has anything to go off of it was
discovered that this cult was put into
the game very late in development and
thus the devs ran out of time to add any
proper backstory to them while i will at
least recognize that there was an
attempt to add backstory assuming that
article is true it wasn't present in the
full release thus i can only go off of
what we have in game this same sort of
storytelling though occurs all the way
up until we meet andrew ryan where there
is that lack of substance in the audio
logs save for a few key logs at specific
points everything we have to do was made
by the devs to add length to the game
and extend its gameplay once again
taking everything into account i don't
mind this as the gameplay was fun and
i'll gladly take another couple hours of
it but when only looking at the story
it's clear we're being dragged along and
constantly stalled for the sake of run
time to get to andrew ryan from here we
need to get through arcadia except
andrew ryan shuts off some of the oxygen
so we need to turn it back online with
the help of julie to turn it on we need
to create the lazarus vector julie was
working on so we need to go from arcadia
to the farmer's market to grab the
materials then go back to arcadia to put
it together we then have to hold out
from a never-ending wave of splicers as
they attempt to shut down the device
after this we travel to fort frolick to
find that bathysphere only for the
artist and serial killer sander cohen to
interrupt us after dealing with him we
make it to hephaestus a large industrial
power plant where we can go to andrew
ryan's office only for it to be locked
to turn off this electrical lock and get
into his office we need to blow up the
power plant using a literal bomb this
takes around 4 or so hours to complete
which doesn't seem like a long time
until you realize this campaign's run
time is close to 10 hours that's also
being extremely generous given the
quality of the bioshock remasters is
awful and continues to crash and this
game doesn't have any consistent auto
saves as the only trigger when you enter
a new level so assuming you get wrapped
up in game play and forget to save like
i did you might be losing a couple
minutes to a whole hour of progress so
if anything it's actually less than 10
hours but still it's clear that a large
portion of the game is within these
levels technically you could argue that
the first few levels do the exact same
thing as it does take quite a bit of
time to get to smuggler's hideout but
not only are these levels short as that
whole sequence takes around half the
time the levels themselves are covered
in numerous audio logs related to the
area or the main boss of said area we've
already discussed before how arcadia
does attempt to do the same but fails by
not providing enough substance farmer's
market suffers from the exact same fate
as arcadia and hephaestus has a couple
important logs that are helpful to
understanding the downfall of rapture
but fort frolick and sandra cohen are
probably the only exception as xander
cohen is actually a really entertaining
villain and there is one extremely
important audio log that has relevance
to the end of the game sander cohen is
extremely creepy and also a bit sad at
the same time he's a poet composer
sculptor and playwright he's clearly
talented in the realm of art but he too
was subjected to the same problems many
had thanks to adam where steinman became
more infatuated with his work thanks to
adam as he attempted to erase all the
problems he had sandra cohen would use
this opportunity to also enhance his
craft he created artwork from his
victims by covering them in plaster and
setting them up in various poses it's
horrifying especially when you discover
that they're actual people as they bleed
when you hit them as i said he's creepy
and his mannerisms and speech reflect
this too but he's also quite the sad
person as his audio logs and even some
dialogue from andrew ryan point to him
seeing us as a spark he needed to keep
going the reason sandra cohen keeps us
here is that he needed help completing
his masterpiece a full four picture
display of his colleagues who betrayed
him next to a ton of bodies it's our job
to kill his colleagues and take their
pictures i do like how the pictures we
take with the camera are the actual
photos and not some preset photo the
devs had in place so nice touch when we
put the third photo in the picture frame
he freaks out claiming that we are
doubting his work in his fit of rage he
has numerous spider splicers attack us
he calms down after a while and does
apologize for the unnecessary outburst
but it's clear that he does not like
people who dislike his work by us
helping cohen and seeing his masterpiece
through to the end we can possibly give
him the strength he needed to keep going
with his artwork and convey to him that
he is indeed an excellent artist it also
seems that he may have planned to kill
andrew ryan at some point as one audio
log says that he wants to create a
requiem for him it's also during this
level where we uncover a very important
scene of jasmine jolene who we find out
as andrew ryan's mistress who's talking
about her recent pregnancy
i'm sorry mr ryan i didn't know
i didn't know fontaine had something to
do with it wha
what are you doing no
no don't play i love you no don't wait
no
[Music]
that creepy doctor tenenbaum promised me
it wasn't gonna be a real pregnancy
they just take the egg out once mr ryan
and i had
oh i needed the money so bad
but i know mr ryan's gonna suss it out
gonna no i wasn't being careful gonna
know i saw the
mr ryan's gonna be so mad at me
from what we gather it seems that andrew
ryan had discovered what occurred and
beat her to death with a pipe this
incident just like many we have
discovered today will be relevant later
but not too much later as after running
through the power plant crafting the
bomb and destroying the power we can
finally come face to face with the man
himself
an assassin has overcome my final
defense
and now he's come to murder me in the
end what separates
a man
from a slave
money
power
no
a man chooses
a slave obeys
you think you have memories
[Music]
a farm
a family
an airplane
a crash
and then this place
was there really a family
did that airplane crash
or was it hijacked forced down
forced down by something less than a man
something bred to sleepwalk through life
until they are activated by a simple
phrase
spoken by their kindly master
was a man sent a kill
or a slave
a man chooses
a slave obeys
would you kindly
powerful phrase
familiar phrase
would you kindly
would you kindly get this would you
kindly find that would you kindly find
that would you kind of
forget this
do you kindly head to ryan's office and
kill the son of a [ __ ]
sit
would you kindly
stand
would you cut
run
a man chooses
a slave obeys
kill
oh my
juices
oh
face
[Music]
this is what makes bioshock so hard to
speak about as so much of this game
revolves around this key moment and
summarizing the journey here in just a
few short sentences is a disservice to
the effort that went into creating this
plot twist right before this we actually
get to see a room that andrew ryan was
working in trying to piece together what
was going on he was confused why there
was some random person who just happened
to survive a plane crash right next to
the entrance to rapture and who is
capable of defeating all that he throws
at him by the time we arrive ryan
manages to uncover the truth we're a
sleeper agent for atlas we from birth
were created to be this way that child
of jasmine's that tenenbaum took from
her was us she paid jasmine for the baby
and conditioned the child to respond to
the phrase would you kindly meaning not
only was atlus lying to us we the player
never had any freedom in our choices and
to top it all off were ryan's son in
some ways it's almost poetic someone who
preaches about men choosing and slaves
obeying has a son who is the complete
opposite of him ryan a man and his son a
slave as if this plot twist wasn't
already bad enough the game isn't done
yet is when we take ryan's genetic key
and put it into the override we stop
rapture from self-destructing but now
give control of rapture to atlas who is
actually frank fontaine this wouldn't
have been as good if it was anyone but
fontaine the one who ran the smuggling
ring in neptune's bounty and the one who
worked with tenenbaum to condition us
was the guy who saved us the whole time
that room from earlier also shows us
some of the experiments jack underwent
before being sent out of rapture such as
when dr sung forced us to snap a dog's
neck because he said the phrase bioshock
without a doubt has one of the best if
not the best plot twist in gaming
history from the moment we have started
the game we had no free will the present
we were given sparked the plane crash so
even before we could play the game we
are being controlled video games as a
whole give the player a choice it could
be small choices like how to kill the
enemy in front of you or it could be a
large choice like the ending of a game
but bioshock took this idea and twisted
it completely by tricking the player
into thinking they had the freedom of
choice when in fact the only choice they
were given was when to turn the game off
this revelation also ties into four
things i've noticed over the years and
i've always wondered if they were
intentional or not firstly jack has a
tattoo of chains on his wrist possibly
signifying that he's a slave to atlas
next is when atlas's family who we
eventually discovered didn't actually
exist blows up in the bathysphere andrew
ryan says maybe you could warn him if
only you could do something except just
stand there and watch him die at this
time in the game ryan doesn't know who
we are so this wasn't intended to be a
double meaning but i believe the devs
made him say this on purpose as this
line can be interpreted as us once again
being a slave to atlas with no way to do
anything about it thirdly when we meet
the little sister at the medical
pavilion atlas never says the words
would you kindly it's possible that not
even tenenbaum knew of atlas's true
identity and if he had said that phrase
over the radio she would have caught on
immediately this is something fontaine
tries to do throughout the story and
that's to play the long game by
convincing us that his family died in
the bathysphere we made our bond with
him even stronger as we now have a
common goal but that's exactly what
fontaine wanted the last thing i noticed
was some symbolism in the first location
minutes into the game as there's a
statue holding up a ball with the words
welcome to rapture on it this is easily
a reference to atlas the greek giant who
is forced to hold up the world for all
eternity this could be seen as a
foreshadowing of atlus trying to hold up
the world of rapture by defeating ryan
and being the leader of the city but
it's also a reference to atlas's demise
as in greek mythology this was atlas's
punishment so this could be
foreshadowing atlas's punishment in game
as he just made us an enemy all of these
might be completely wrong but the fact
that they line up so well with the
game's themes and story make it
impossible to see it as a coincidence
from its plot twist to its symbolism
it's one of the best writing i've ever
seen however we're still not done with
the game yet fontaine has betrayed us
and without any real objective anymore
it's only fair that we enact the same
revenge again but on the man who
actually deserves it during the reveal
of fontaine he says goodbye and launches
an army of security bots to chase us
during our escape a little sister
appears and guides us to safety before
falling down the vent shaft we awaken
and discover that we are in a secret
room in rapture where the little sisters
relax and play together it's a really
cute moment as we can see all the little
sisters interacting with one another
tenenbaum then informs us that she was
able to reduce some of the mental
conditioning that fontaine put on us but
we aren't completely cured to achieve
this we need to head to dr sung's
laboratory and find his cure for it
fontaine now the head of rapture notices
that we're awake and attempts to shut us
down but only ends up being able to
lower our health a bit by making our
hearts stop momentarily it's a lot
better than being completely manipulated
but he can still control us in some way
so we definitely need that cure the
location where this cure is found is a
place called olympus heights where all
the super rich stayed in luxury
apartments many characters we've already
talked about today like tennenbaum dr su
chong and even sandra cohen lived in
these apartments i've always found it
interesting how these apartments are
right next to apollo square which is
known for housing the poor and homeless
you can even tell from the railroad
station next to each area as the area
near olympus heights is quite pristine
given the circumstances and the one in
apollo square is extremely run down both
the audio logs and the environment will
tell us that there was clearly a
revolution starting here and at the head
of this was atlas in order to avoid
suspicion and hide under the radar
fontaine faked his own death and changed
his name and face to atlas we learned in
arcadia that atlas was at one point a
politician but he claimed those days
were over it seemed that fontaine was
using the poor as his army and there is
numerous audio logs to back this theory
up andrew ryan wanted to create the
perfect society but it fell victim to
social status and given his own policies
within rapture there wasn't much
opportunity to crawl back to the middle
class those who were rich succeeded and
those who were poor suffer just like
every other society in existence
fontaine sees this opportunity to gather
an army of like-minded individuals and
use them to do his bidding going back to
neptune's bounty we have a couple audio
logs from peaches that talk about how he
disliked ryan and preferred fontaine's
way of running things at least initially
until he realized that fontaine might
actually be worse than ryan this really
shows that even rapture was doomed to
fail as a society the only way it was
possible to save this city was for ryan
to help the poor and make sure everyone
was happy but given his own beliefs and
the beliefs of rapture that was never
going to happen the downfall of rapture
didn't happen overnight it was a long
string of events that progressively got
worse and worse the atom addiction the
mistreatment of the poor the
manipulation of fontaine the actual
culture surrounding rapture all of it
contributed to its demise getting back
to the story we end up finding the cure
for our mental conditioning and allowed
jack complete freedom for the first time
in his life one thing that's important
to note is his freedom because it's not
like he was completely controlled he
still did things in his life before
coming to rapture but he was never
completely free as fontaine could easily
change that by saying one simple phrase
while gathering the cure we also found a
dead body on the table and discovered
that it's dr shu chong's quite ironic
that dr su chong died to his own
creation he was of course the original
creator of the big daddies and was the
one who created that defense mechanism
in them that attacks anyone who hurts
the little sisters good to see that he's
dead given how much pain he caused
people after finding the cure we can now
kill fontaine except before we get a
chance to heal locks the door of the
educational facility which is only
unlocked via a big daddy which means we
need to become a big daddy despite how
bothersome this area can be in regards
to its confusing layout and plethora of
enemies from a lore perspective it's
quite intriguing as this is the facility
where the big daddies and little sisters
were made one thing that's been missing
from this game so far is the who the big
daddies are and how they were made and
thankfully this area answers that
question it seems that the big daddies
are people who had their skin and organs
grafted to the suits which may explain
why they can't take them off in jack's
case he didn't need to graft his skin
and organs to the suit as he just needed
to trick the system into thinking he was
a big daddy which is why he isn't
injured during the process however he
does need a voice module so he can sound
like one and just by looking at the
device it definitely doesn't look safe
after becoming a big daddy we help out a
little sister who gives us a syringe and
unlocks the final locked door to
fontaine where we can now finally start
the boss fight and both this and the
endings of bioshock are honestly quite
bad fontaine is a giant creature now
flowing with adam and while i'm willing
to just barely believe something like
this is possible the fight overall is
just bad all you do during the fight is
shoot him until his health is gone and
then when he returns to his machine to
gather more atom you stab him with the
syringe and you do this four times until
he dies you would think after the second
time he would stop recharging his atom
this way but apparently not the boss
fight does ramp up in difficulty as the
security bots and splicers come to his
aid but it's sort of hard to ignore the
giant naked man trying to kill you
especially when he functions just like a
big daddy and stuns you when you're hit
after defeating him he'll smack you one
more time and all the little sisters
will come out and aid you by stabbing
him which admittedly is pretty cool
afterward the game goes into one of
three endings and the conditions of the
ending depend on whether or not you
harvested or saved the little sisters
one ending is when you save all of them
the other is when you harvest all of
them and a third is if you do a mix of
both you don't need to rescue every
single little sister but out of the ones
you interacted with within the game you
do have to save them i do like the happy
ending where all the little sisters grow
up and live normal lives before all
meeting again to be with you on your
deathbed but the other is just bizarre
as jack takes control of rapture for
himself and uses the splicers as an army
to overtake the surface and launch a
nuke like the ending started okay but
ramped up in intensity immediately why
does jack need a nuke why bother killing
those on the surface what was even the
point of this ending this just like the
morality of harvesting and rescuing the
little sisters was something the
developers wish they had improved on for
the final release regardless we have
made it to the end of the game and thus
finished the story of bioshock this game
is without a doubt one of the best of
all time it truly has one of the best
stories in the gaming industry and is
one i wish i could experience again for
the first time bioshock has an
incredible level of detail put into its
story from its world building to its
story of specific characters this couple
with its incredible plot twist makes
this a very hard game to beat when it
comes to comparing its stories it's one
game i will always recommend without
hesitation and was the perfect start to
a brand new series
thank you all for watching today and i
hope you didn't mind the change in
direction with this video as it started
to become a more of a storyteller video
as i incorporated many small plots like
steinmen the creation of atom as well as
the audio logs to further discuss them i
normally wouldn't have done this but
bioshock became quite the tough video to
talk about when i didn't include these
extra details so i hope it was still
entertaining thank you for making it
this far and if you enjoyed be sure to
like and subscribe if you're new and
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back i haven't decided whether
the next video in this style of
commentary will be the sequel to this
game or another series but we'll just
have to see if you have a game you want
me to talk about be sure to let me know
in the comments below i've gotten asked
quite a bit to talk about the arkham
series as well as the borderlands games
which are already on my list so
excellent thinking
with that however take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
you